must be on call because it looks like
your backend needs some attention.
Welcome back everybody. Today we'll be
doing some wrapups of database indexes.
Now, I would like to implore all of you
viewers because I consider myself a role
model to all of you that this is the
only time you should ever be dealing
with anything pertaining to wrap-ups. I
recommend in all aspects of life. And in
addition to that, as with systems
design, you can always fall back on plan
B. So, without further ado and without
any more corny jokes, let's get into the
subject for today. All right, so let's
go ahead and get into things. I've got
the iPad up and we can get started. I've
done a lot of prewriting again, so we
can hopefully make this an even faster
lesson. So to basically wrap up the
entire point of indexes. I mentioned
this in the introduction to indexes
video, but now that you know how they're
actually implemented, you should
understand this point a little bit
better. The main point of indexes is the
following. Obviously, we want to use
them to get faster reads on a specific
key value. That means, for example, if I
have a bunch of different columns in a
database table, I get to pick one of
those columns, put an index on it, and I
know now that if I'm searching for all
columns with a value on that specific
column, then it is going to be made
quite significantly faster. On the
contrary, the problem here now is that
every single write that I do to this
database table is going to be
significantly slower as opposed to just
appending to the end of some, you know,
disk file. Now I have to do that plus
also deal with the logarithmic time
complexity that's incurred dealing with
either a B tree or an LSM tree and SS
tables. So for now I'm going to scroll
down a little bit and basically the way
I want to kind of think throughout this
video is think about the index from an
abstraction point of view. So for right
now let's throw out the kind of idea of
the hash index and think about just the
abstraction. Right? So basically if we
have an index on a key imagine that that
basically means that we are sorting our
database table by that key. The entire
point is that our database is sorted so
that we can do O of login binary
searches on it both for individual row
reads and also range queries. So imagine
that we have some like almost like
Twitter post database right here where
we have an index on the username of the
poster and then we also have like a date
column and the actual text of what I
posted. As you can see, the keys are
themselves sorted in alphabetical order.
So I know that if I were to ever go and
look for the specific key that I want,
it's not like finding a needle in a hay
stack anymore. There's actually an
organized way of finding this key. And
so again, that takes that read time
complexity from a linear time scan to a
logarithmic time scan, which is really
huge, especially when you have a super
large database table. So this is kind of
the main idea of indexes, right? We've
taken this read, which would have been
otherwise super complicated. we've made
it a lot faster and of course it is
going to give us a right penalty. But
when you are for example an app that
heavily relies on making read speeds
super fast for you know kind of good
performance for your customers that is
sometimes a worthwhile trade-off.
Everything in systems design has
trade-offs and the index is a perfect
example of one of them that comes along
with databases. Okay so basically what
we have written right over here as you
can see this is what's called a
clustered index. So I kind of acted as
if all indexes were clustered indexes in
my past videos, right? Where I
insinuated that the data of the row
itself was stored within the index. So
in this case, the data of the row would
be the date and the text of the post.
However, the truth of the matter is a
lot of times you're not necessarily
using a clustered index. So the benefit
of a clustered index is that you get
faster reads, right? Because you
literally go and search through your
index and then right once you're there,
you can actually access the data
directly. But instead, a lot of the time
what indexes will do is they will
actually just go ahead and put the
address of the corresponding row on disk
within the index. So basically the main
advantage of this second type of index
where we've only got disk addresses
instead of the actual data in the row is
less data duplication. So this is really
really huge for us in the sense mainly
that uh you know now we don't have to
duplicate every single row in all of the
indexes that we have. So, one thing that
you'll see in a lot of databases that
it's common to have more than one index.
Perhaps there are two fields that we
want to optimize our reads on. And so,
if we have two fields with indexes, that
means that every single row that we
write would have to entirely fit in both
of those index. So, imagine we took this
entire gigantic uh clustered index right
here and had to double it. Now, we're
basically storing two times as much
data. And obviously, that's going to be
unacceptable if we're trying to optimize
the amount of data that we're storing.
it is not worth it to do that. And so
again, that's why this kind of address
index is the one that you see used more
often in practice. There is also a
middle ground known as kind of like a
covered uh index where as opposed to
storing all of the fields like you see
right here, maybe we would only store
one important field and then the other
one is elsewhere on disk or we would
have, you know, an address on disk,
whatever. Um, but the general point is,
you know, we would only have a subset of
fields in the index. And that kind of
provides that trade-off where you're
storing less data, but you know, you
still have faster reads for the fields
that we want in the index.
Okay. So, the last thing that I plan on
covering in this video is the concept of
a multi-dimensional index. So, we've
covered, you know, what an index on a
single field is, but a lot of the times
what you'll want is kind of a combo
index where not only do we have um an
index on one field, but within that
sorted order, we also want uh basically
an internal sorted order. We don't just
want it to be random. So, imagine I was
a social media site and I want to
organize all of my posts first by the
username of the poster and then also by
the date that they posted, right? So for
example, as you can see here, what's
actually going to go ahead and happen is
we have the name sorted and then the
date sorted. So the the later the date
of posting, uh, basically the later down
it's going to be in that database table.
Keep in mind this is in contrast to
having two separate indexes on the name
and date field, right? So for example,
if we were to have an index on the date
field, then the rows would actually be
in chronological order. And it would be
something like, you know, January 1st,
then February 5th, then March 10th,
then over here, June 1st, then September
10th, and then December 1st. So the
order would completely switch if we
wanted an index just on the date field.
But because we have this kind of
multi-dimensional composite index, it's
one sort order. first on the name and
then afterwards we sort every single key
internally on the name in the date. And
so that is also a really useful feature
that is as if you just had one index,
right? Two separate indexes will sort
each field individually. So I just
wanted to go ahead and clear that up.
All right, everyone. Well, I hope this
video was useful. Um, looking forward to
seeing you guys in the next one. I'm
going to switch up the order a little
bit from my original series because I'm
thinking that it will benefit us to kind
of do all the database internal stuff
first and then we can start talking
about things like replication and
partitioning where we're going not just
from one computer or one database but to
many database nodes in a cluster. Okay,
looking forward to it and I will see you
guys in the next